Thank You lucky and well I will tell you
certain about self-programming networks
see how that goes
this is work I'm doing with a number of
people at Stanford notably Mendel
Rosenblum is a colleague operating
systems virtual machines and then Dan
Jiang is a senior scientist plus the
number of students of whom VIN such as
Anand I see here and so there's our
group it's a question make networks
autonomous and if you take your research
topic and just add self driving to it in
front of it like self-driving stable
matchings it just sounds better okay you
know you're more than that there could
be anything you know it's it's
self-driving doorknobs this is better
okay
our goal is to make networks autonomous
like you know that is your sense and
monitor itself program and control
itself and be interactive okay so we
think of our work as a combination of
engineering and design this means I will
show you a demo at the end and how to
think of this well let's think of
self-driving cars what does that mean
you can take a plain old car like a fox
one and Touareg if you had sense and
control to it it will become Stanley the
self-driving car Sebastian that Stanley
the idea is by just by taking a car in
adding lidar and
[Music]
you know mapping and where is other
things and controlling the steering and
acceleration you create the self-driving
thing okay so just so we want to take a
plain old data center this is any data
center that you can see either large or
small smaller be 500,000 large would be
a hundred thousand or a million and they
all look pretty much like this what is
called a leaf spine topology so it's a
multi-stage switching topology these are
all the servers this is who wants to
talk to each other get some work done
and this is the switching interconnect
fabric okay and the data center supports
some number of apps and it processes
workload coming from data related to
these apps that's really you know what
it does okay as far as our talk is
concerned but yes where's the sheet
metal here say this network might be
serving mobile applications the apps are
all here in the sheet none really
in the switches is in the switches and
the service just think of just plain
servers servers in Iraq and the racks
are connected okay everything this
happens is happening on top of it
so to this data center we want to add
some sensing and control and get
ourselves a self programming Network and
so I will tell you exactly what we sent
so where is sensing happening and then
what sort of problems come up for
processing the sensed data and then what
sort of control can does not lead us to
exert okay and the control can be a
function of network state as well as
operator policies okay it's no different
from you know self-driving cars cars
have to respond to what's around them
but you may have some policies like you
know don't go faster than 60 miles per
hour sort of thing as an example or if
you have particular cars then don't go
on some kind of roads that's an example
don't let this app take more than next
amount of bandwidth
don't let these virtual machines of ten
and a swamp and take up all the CPU
cycles and starve the other guy but that
sort of thing so I'm gonna do with
amount of compute network bandwidth and
storage some service level agreement
that they had she it was an internal
data center then it'll be just decided
internally usually they were very
dynamic the dynamic not in themselves
the dynamic and in that the enactment of
this depends on dynamic state of the
network so what does this get us it gets
us some new functionality not available
in the plain old data center like very
accurate time stamping is the service
fine grained network telemetry and
application network performance
monitoring I won't tell you about all of
them I will tell you where the first two
but that means you can now run some new
applications that you could not run on
the plain old data center for example a
global distributed database like spanner
this is Google's they you know global
database what that means is it
guarantees you consistency what's called
external consistency strongest form
ocular clocks across the globe okay
that's something you can run on this
plain old data center now the corner and
planar data center it doesn't have those
time-stamping at service but if you
enhance it then you can run it that's an
example any consensus algorithms are
usually designed to from you know from
some sort of message passing foundation
but if you have accurate clocks you can
speed that up that's an example new
things you can do I already talked about
this Monday last week we had a one day
symposium and I know the audience is not
fully overlapping but I don't want to
revisit the the financial industry also
cares a lot about accurate clocks I
think my talks online if in case you're
interested so I'm just gonna stick with
two two algorithms I promised namely
these two so where is the sensing and
control everything is for us going to
happen or the network interface cards
this is what we're gonna do primarily
not exclusively and how that happens I
will tell you in a second
this is the work itself consists of
thinking about Nick
based stuff and then having this query
engine
let us speaking to this self programming
network and we use a lot of data and
machine learning to speed up Hardware
accelerate and I'll show you that much
more specifically so what a sensing mean
the Nick's mean I will look at packets
data packets or probes probes are
special packets that we insert I will
look at the time at which they're
transmitted and the time at which they
received and using these two time stamps
reconstruct how long the packet spent at
each of the intermediate boxes okay this
is known as network tomography it's an
it's a topic that's been around in the
internet context where it has achieved
limited success just because the wire
time in Internet is way bigger than the
box time so you end up
fortunately not being able to
reconstruct accurately so as soon as you
see this you can identify one problem if
these clocks aren't well synchronized
you all of this approaches useless right
because the time taken in a data center
to go from one side to the other is
usually a few microseconds under no
congestion of you like 10 microseconds
and under congestion it's about in
alternative microseconds often babysat
there isn't really that much time and
the clock synchronization is not good
this is not help you need this approach
won't work okay that's one thing the
second thing is to also note that the
you know there are details and I'm not
going to cover but let's assume you know
the path these are systems issues
there's ways of knowing this let's
assume that okay this has been
implemented in different or a layer to
type networks and layer 3 and you can
sort of use different things available
there if you look at what the system
part so everything I've told you so far
is you're sensing and inferring we're
waiting on the smart mix to come out in
industry to do control but they're
coming out lots of companies are
building smart mix but let me continue
on telling you I really want to tell you
what the algorithms that go here ok so
the pipeline itself would look like
there's a data center there are times
times taken from probes and data packets
in just the way I told you there's a
[ __ ] synchronization step followed by
equivalent reconstruction step this is
solving this simultaneous nonlinear
equations of you know breaking down by
individual box from the total end-to-end
time and then also decomposing it by
whose packets are in the queue and then
I hope to have enough time to do a quick
demo so there's a few places has been
tried out but on some large ones and
some homegrown one you know Stanford one
gigabit a second testbed it looks like
this this is the testbed ok
I won't tell you more about what's this
one of the servers and what the switches
are if you know networking if you've
done this sort of thing before it'll be
obvious otherwise that's not worry about
okay for the rest of the talk I want to
tell you about two algorithms and that's
it in the show demo okay so let me start
with the algorithm that presumes the
existence of accurate clock synchronizes
a synchronous synchronized clocks and
tell you how the reconstruction was so
let's first start with just I have data
packets only no probes okay and I'm
taking the timestamp those data packets
then this equation says the one-way
delay the time taken from transmit to
receive that is a one-way delay of each
packet equals the sum of the times it
spent at the individual boxes on the
path plus some propagation delay and
there's some noise here because the
wires on all of equal length these mix
don't apply times times exactly when
they transmit the packets there are
other things called dark matter packets
these are pockets not emitted by the
switches but they're there in the box
switches are talking to each other to
discover who's my neighbor there's
various things like this okay and one of
those packets get in front of one of our
packets and they may use other
priorities but in our Stanford test but
they don't use other priority so when
they mainly small delay so this is in
the order a few tens of nanoseconds this
is in microseconds to hundreds of
microseconds okay so there's a it is
indeed noise okay okay this so we solve
this using the lasso algorithm and I'm
just gonna write down for just for
completeness what it is our criterion is
to try and minimize we want an estimate
of the queue this is a vector of queues
I want an estimate of this such that
the it is minimum mean square error
estimate so this is so choose an
estimate such that this is minimized for
reasons that so let me just read our
orders equation is in a millisecond of
time or in a certain amount of time
smalls time which depends on the speed
of the line I will tell you about how to
pick time one packet goes through and
you will write this equation down the
set of cues it visited is represented by
the adjacency matrix the first rows
adjacency matrix picks the cues in this
vector of cues that the first packet
visit visited and the second entry here
is another packet going from some source
of some other destination and the set of
cues it visited and so on okay that's
what this is sorry I didn't say that
before okay
now one of this I wanted minimum mean
square estimate for reasons that are
don't have to do just that where the
network topology ease that is but it's
sort of multi-state switching topology
this matrix is always going to have less
than full rank so your solution is going
to be under determined the questions
aren't to determine but the way the
congestion happens in these networks is
it sparse and not all the entries of Q
are going to be equally large okay so
there's just the fact that data centers
are there's many many parts means only
some queues are you have lots of choice
of paths so I said a few things there
so we want to minimize this s do we want
to find an estimate of the cube that
minimizes this it is always the case
in that with this criterion that the
conditional expectation of Q given D is
the best estimate okay and one way to
find this is to look at an equation of
this type so this is known this is known
this is not known and try and find the
minimizing Q okay
but since it's under determine and we're
looking for a spar solution you add this
held one norm so that this whole thing
is still convex and you can solve this
and find the minimizer and declare that
to be the estimate it means quite a rare
estimate okay this is the last one the
algorithm that takes this cost function
and determines the answer is the last
value faster algorithm he's an algorithm
that does it for a single packet which
is what each entry is there's only one
path a flows packets may have different
paths for each packet is only one path
straightforwardly this is you know it's
the convex cross function you will take
the derivative said you know that's the
name Lasser comes from yeah there's a
rhetorical reason for that that's right
laughter is the name of yeah it's it's
also it's an acronym okay okay la is in
capitals because we've empirically
accused the data center is partially
occupied
I have some numbers in the thing later q
is for if Q is thousand d DS up to us
because how much measurements we're
going to take but DS in the order of 500
typically when Q and Q is thousand
boring for a big Network these numbers
of bigger many values of lambda work so
it's not a very robust thing okay they
will give you slightly different answers
but for the non zero ones it's not
appreciably different so with that let's
see how it works I'm gonna start with an
s3 which is a simulator and I'm get to
the real network something there is a
queue that connects over one to top of
the racks which is zero and the blue
line is the actual ground truth and the
red line is the fit a solution from
lasso the root mean square error is
small and it picks up small you know the
small bumps and everything so that's a
fit and then if you look at sometimes it
doesn't work well and what's going on is
that is if I just have data packets it
is very badly under determined okay that
is there's just not enough equations so
there's a miss imputation going on
there's a queue here in fact but it's
miss imputed to being there and so on
okay okay this happens there's nothing I
can do this is under determined it
depends on workload okay depends how the
traffic is flowing instead if we had a
mesh of queues this measure probes sorry
these are probes are we're emitting
small packets they get cooled with the
data packets they're just picking up
extra equations for us okay
the network of probes is a random
network that is each guy probes ten or
fifteen or so is randomly and the number
ten or fifteen is felled fixed
regardless of how many servers that are
in total okay it's a random graph
man you still saw the same thing you
just have additional equations and you
can show that it solves the problem
meaning you'll determine all the queue
sizes in fact even improve the errors
and the questions I want to answer is
what is being measured precisely why
does it work and how can this be speeded
up because we find lasso takes time so
in a data center on it on a 10 or 40
gigabit per second link you don't have
more than a millisecond for
reconstruction if it's real time on a 10
gig link and 1/4 millisecond a 40 gig
link so we need something that's going
to help us speed up the lasso then one
tell us about these two things why does
it work ok so what is what is being Sam
what is being in what is being
reconstructed the actual queue size on
attending a bit per second link if you
look at the queue at the time at which a
packet is killed in or taken out and
that happens every 1.2 microseconds and
attend a link so let's make it 1
microsecond it'll look like this if you
take thousand of these readings
successive thousand readings and average
them but it's add their values and
divide by 1000 you'll give this
millisecond average so in other words
it's just some filtered version of so
we're gonna reconstruct this not only is
that easier to reconstruct that is you
know switches will give you numb things
that look like this but the morrow data
here is just huge ok and so now just
digging into that a little bit more if I
have 10 gigabits per second sample
without any with per second link and I
sampled the queue one microsecond one
microsecond I get this and when I look
at the one millisecond average I get
what I showed you that is that is what's
happening in the network what we're
doing on the other hand is I have a mesh
of probes and the probing at some
frequency
for in this talk I won't tell you how to
determine the frequency at which to pro
not enough time but we're gonna probe
them at some frequency so literally
what's going on in this example is for
every millisecond I launch a bunch of
probes from different servers destined
for you know other servers and I look at
the time that they spent and call that
back milliseconds water data and ship it
to this algorithm to go reconstruct and
then that'll be one point in this graph
then go to the next millisecond repeat
this okay that's what's happening and
that's what this is and we take the
probes data estimate it and then we're
going to say that but what we get here
is an estimate of that that's what we're
doing we just make observations and
average them and you might observations
have to terms of queue length and
average so that's not lesser estimated
yes no no that is just a definite so I
took the queue size process and just
took a moving window average alright you
know just non-overlapping windows off I
I applied an operation to this thing to
get this is not lasso that's just what
I'm saying we're going to reconstruct
this
when you when you estimate something
with lesser you don't observe the
killings just observe from origin to
destination of the pair killers right
that's right I'm trying to give a
theoretical reason no I'm not I'm saying
this is what we're doing we're claiming
that this is going to estimate that I'm
not observing that but I have to prove
to you that this is in fact gonna
estimate that right so this this
simulated system or I can measure it in
reality just for right it's the ground
truth so the first thing I want to do is
why does this microsecond average and
really see what's going on here okay so
is this a sensible thing to do so if you
look at the thing in the frequency
domain meaning you take the
autocorrelation function of the one
microsecond queue size process take the
Fourier transform it's two-sided but
it's an even function so you plot on one
side you'll get this this is how much
power is in what frequency okay
and this is for the 1 micro second
sample thing and if I superimpose the 1
milli second average it is exactly the
same this shouldn't be so this is
expected to be okay and there are no
frequencies beyond 500 kilohertz because
they're all averaged out just what
should be but what we're doing is you
can take a moving average of 1,000
points out you know thing and then down
sample it so you heard a little bit of
this flavor of things in the previous
speakers talk okay and that's what this
is doing and if you look at what's
happening the frequency domain you're
going to get this aliased thing and
you're going to pick one of them okay
that is that is effectively what this
you know one millisecond average is
doing but the point of this graph is
what is the power captured in this blue
thing that signal we're interested in
how much of the original thing is is
still captured okay so notice that the
y-axis log scale the one millisecond
average guy has in excess of 97% of the
power okay so the one microsecond guy in
the one millisecond are pretty much
identical except for two two and a half
to three percent power okay that's how
much noise so what has been removed is
this a very significant amount yeah
therefore is the right thing to
reconstruct but this is true across a
variety of different networks different
package sizes and various things okay so
if I take a one gigabit per second
network at ten and so one ten and a 40
then and I say I I'm looking to see what
fraction of power I want left behind
so that's 97% there okay nine and a half
actually then it tells you what is the
right interval to average over which
means for the for the system we're
developing you know what interval of
probes are you going to you know solve
last so far and the number for a one big
line is 10 milliseconds for 10 gig lines
one millisecond and so on okay so that
is the interval over which you'll have
to keep solving laso what are the
implications of acknowledgments not
being
failed good question so there'll be a
blank entry you can either choose to
include it or not yeah yeah so you can
you can just say I lost a packet is very
helpful to include that information that
is some buffer offload okay that's very
useful include yeah
nobody even data packets without matter
they're indistinguishable from and the
purpose the algorithm and there's probes
haven't more easy we're getting through
because they're shorter it's it's harder
problem than it probably did a packet
okay let me continue that announced
definitely behind time so one of the
things that we ran into was just this
last algorithm was taking time to solve
and has doesn't scale as well so you
know it's it's easy to use natural to
ask the question even if I take the
output of lasso for multiple pairs of so
think of this as a map class there's a
map that given D is going to give us a Q
so for a given D I got a Q and I have
multiple DQ pairs so if I take all this
DQ pairs and go train a neural network
my dad helped me to speed up the
solution every okay this so you can
never solve lasso or you can teach
numeric solve it and the weights are
size and since the governing equation is
really linear equation with noise
there's some hope that it's not going to
be horrible so that's what we did so it
took lasso as black box angle all there
isn't and then we train a neural network
just to see what acceleration one can
get and I'm not good everybody knows
what radios are so I'm just you know
this is end of training second decade
front every notice I'm not gonna spend
time explaining this okay well the
important thing is just a to too low to
it one hidden layer it's not this is a
shallow here's a network okay we want to
know what's the quality of
reconstruction but neural network how
well is it learning lasso itself and how
does it learn ground truth when you can
supply it
what is the speed-up that you get that's
the more important thing okay from our
perspective
and here's the answer so first thing is
the quality the root means quite a deter
so I think someone asks what are the
sizes so the not in the system where the
256 servers there's one more coming down
here how many cues how many parts and
how many DS okay so let's focus on this
one what this is saying is the root
means quite error for lasso alone versus
a near electric train with ground truth
not with lasso or train with lasso this
pretty good performance so just to give
you an idea what that means why am i
declaring is good 1500 byte packet is
the size of a TCP packet so this is
about three and a half packets so this
is like super small you know errors and
so you can now filter on both packets is
one packet
now here's the more interesting thing
from our perspective even if you use
past versions of lasso every
milliseconds worth of data takes this
amount of time for even modest size data
centers or subnets whereas this one is
like really fast it allows you to things
like batching and we took a pretty
straightforward GPU that's something
that comes with the virtual realities
had a system vibe so this isn't even
optimized GPU so but you get it you get
an order manager comparison so it's like
it's five or ten thousand X faster this
is the point what you don't have ground
shoes we don't have ground truth you may
know the end-to-end data you don't know
the switch sizes right queue size on the
switch not for these many cubes now so
okay that's a connects up a few things
right
so now quickly let me tell you this okay
and I know there's a break coming so
what I'll do is I'll offer to show you a
demo during break time okay so clock
synchronization is just well known hard
or like it's been a problem around we've
all known about the distributor system
people we just like you have a deal with
things are just synchronizing and
whether it's databases or now
distributor Ledger's or various other
things you have to synchronize clocks or
if you have synchronize clocks then I
think life is much better I'll leave
this for the paper reading so the point
is either you have software solutions
that are inaccurate or hardware assisted
solutions that are pretty expensive what
you would like is a software solution
that's inaccurate okay and that's what
we're going to look at
so almost all clock synchronization
algorithms between a pair of servers a
and B who each have their clocks marking
time as T sub a and T sub B which are
you know off from the actual time by
some unknown discrepancies will exchange
probes okay so you get four x times you
use these four x times as follows
receive time of a probe it always equals
the actual transfer me time plus some
whatever delayed there was and if you
write it in terms of the act the time
stamps and no less the unknown
discrepancies is an equation if you put
the unknowns on one side you'll get this
equation and if I remove this positive
quantity I will get a bound on the probe
in the reverse direction I will get a
lower bound with the other two x times
if you plot the bounds this is how it's
going to look so this is from the Google
40g testament what this is is the time
according
the clock a he's on the x-axis they are
known discrepancy for which we are
bounds each blue door is an upper bound
he's green orders a lower bound the
ignore these guys in the middle for a
second this thick blue line and thick
green line are the shortest time to go
from A to B and be the way respectively
so this is the one way this is a
round-trip time this gap
assuming the path the symmetric in the
sense that forwards time and backwards
time are equal or nearly equal you're
left with finding this middle red line
and suppose you find it it's still not
telling you about the dots in between
I'll come to that okay if you do then
what you can say is when the clock at
server a said zero the claw cursor would
be said whatever nine ninety three point
something okay - the clock resolve is
running slower by that amount okay and
two minutes later he's fallen further
behind that's because the two clocks
have a relative frequency difference
indicated by the slope of this line in
fact the relative frequency difference
be sticking slower than a by this amount
of microseconds per second so two clocks
are perfectly synchronized the slope of
intercept should be both zero okay so
now most most schemes just what you know
try and set the offset you know
correctly offside determinant correct
the offset but as you can see the
frequency is just you know not good from
you know there is a clock frequencies
are off this is actually a mild form of
drift this is from different pairs of
servers or whether in the same rack or
separated by one one level of spine
switch or two and so on and they all
have different slopes and intercepts
okay now just to tell you a little bit
about the points in the middle they're
noisy Nick time stamps and this
sometimes is network interface cards
time stamp after the packets gone so you
artificially here a small propagation
time smaller than possible propagation
time right every okay this so in this
room if I say support vector machines is
of course because you know classify that
blue dots and there's labeled okay data
and you just have to find a separating
hyperplane and you will use a soft
margin support vector machine so it's
not to worry about these guys okay but
this is empirically showing you that
often the clocks are off by five to ten
microseconds per second relative to one
another these pairs of clocks the Kimmy
has badly drifting from the some pair
that's going apart is 30 microseconds
per second
okay so from now on so this is a if you
look over longer periods of time that
the clocks frequency difference is not
linearly related they're some clock is
ticking slower and slower and slower
this happens when they get hot and they
get hot when they pump a lot of packets
so we can deliberately make this happen
everyone we've made it happen
we even take them blow dryers and made
them hotter okay so you can do these
things okay so what we do is we
synchronize everything into second
chunks and that two-second interval if
the frequency difference isn't present I
mean it doesn't kick in so in other the
minute or so I will tell you about this
findings middle red line this is the
algorithm part so I will there are three
things to say first it's about two
machines like I said it will give you
the two support vectors and the
separating hyperplane
as you can see at this level of zoom
it's not really a good fit because
there's noisy stuffs like interfering
with its performance but already you can
synchronize the cost about 300 400 nano
seconds of accuracy
now if we could find a way to send a
probe and get a certificate that this
was a pure probe that it encountered no
noise no queuing delays nothing no life
will be great okay so how do we do that
because this is networking data you can
actually do it so think of each probe is
actually two probes sent back to back
they happen to be separated by some
amount in their transmitted times times
in this example they're separated by ten
microseconds it could be whatever the
number is then on the outside on the
reception side three things can happen
either they come separated by a lot more
than they went in in which case second
guy got delayed regardless of whether
the first guy got delayed are not second
hour delayed more so that's why it
separately so throw away all those or it
shrunk then we'll throw away all those
then they come apart almost equal
meaning up to 50 nanosecond type guard
band okay we will keep those because
it'd be a miracle if the network somehow
managed to give both of them exactly
same delay the most likely explanation
is they got zero queuing delay anything
positive for one to master exactly for
the other network has to be pretty
devious okay same goes for noise type
some noise so if you take that data we
had before and apply that filter you
will lose 90% of the bad stuff and keep
90% of the good stuff okay now this
already leads to an improvement of a
factor of four in the accuracy of clocks
okay so finally this is like what what
else is there left to exploit clocks
have been synchronized pairwise
typically you know over a tree that's
typically how NTP functions okay but if
you observe that clock synchronization
has to be not just reflexive and
symmetric the desire to synchronize with
myself if I'm synchronized BBN sprinkles
with me it also be transitive then
obviously it'll get this extra final
thing where two clocks are mutually
synchronized and they think they're off
by 15 minutes that's the offset and then
B and C are mutually synchronized and B
says if I'm at 10:15 C must be at 10:05
now finally C says if I'm at no.5 a must
be at 9:50 so by going around the loop
the detect that the not well
synchronized and then the question is
how do you apportion this I mean how do
you collect the error there's various
ways and when you pull all the loops in
this program together you can correct it
there's an algorithm for doing it okay
and this the important thing is the as
you increase the number of other servers
you're probing the number of loops will
increase so this network effect will
help you the mean error will come down
but more importantly the 99th percentile
is going to come down a lot more it is
just difficult for you to have outliers
when you go around these loops and start
getting people to agree okay so that's
the algorithm there's a whole bunch in
this analysis and stuff there's a whole
bunch of other things it works well at
high load and it's still under 40 nano
second type accuracy at high load this
is 428 servers okay I don't have time
for demo so I'll stop I I do have it
here okay if you want to thank you it
already so what am I going to friendly
chair okay thank you okay so I told you
there's a dashboard this is what it
looks like so each each grey box there
is a server and each green thing is a
top of the rack so these are all servers
the 16 servers per top of the racks
which there are eight top of the rack so
128 servers ignore the orange guys
that's to prove the accuracy of clock
saying we're not going to worry about
that these guys are connected to each
other through a layer of spine switches
blue spine switches these are alerts
since you've taken a NIC based approach
is very easy so the number one prop
indication of your network has a probe
is that some pocket had to be
retransmitted and the number two problem
and more severe is that some TCP source
timed out so since both are easier for a
NIC to detect those alerts can be raised
okay so the demo itself is we've taken
all these timestamps I send a receiver
next clocks have been synchronized and
this is from the basement data center
Stanford okay
so you can reconstruct the exact way in
which the files got transferred
that's a request going from you know so
there's a so called
in cost load which if you know
networking it means this guy is
requesting three other servers to send
files simultaneously this happens with
Facebook you know when you go and you
download your Facebook page your web
service requesting the simultaneously so
this switch is gonna get overload and
drop packets okay so it's a it's it's a
it's a particularly bad workload from a
congestion perspective the clock here if
you can see it's taking a microseconds
in case of micro seconds and
milliseconds microseconds milliseconds
seconds like that so you can really
observe this very fine great everything
is reconstructed so other guys are doing
file transfers and you can accelerate
like a video you can just watch nothing
happens the level of Microsoft data
centers are not that fun to look at
they're not exactly there's nothing
happening you have to wait like for a
long time before something happens okay
so you can just fast-forward this or you
can raise alerts only go look at time so
alert or you can sort of if you're
impatient you can even do that okay and
so you can sort of this all what I'm
making is is all reconstructed I don't
have a switch based telemetry nothing
right so it's like algorithms the reason
we're all here and then it can get very
cluttered to do all this sort of viewing
so you can sort of say I don't want to
look at everything I just show me the
stuff that goes through that switch and
only that switch for meaning I don't
want it so just hide everything away so
you can sort of build these things and I
think this makes life of very
easy for those who want a debug stuff so
if any of you have played with an s3 or
anis to one this it's a painful thing
okay no grad students would be suffering
anymore okay look at this and then this
is a view that says at a given time what
does the subnet or a network look like
right the deal of view would be if I
pick a link or a location in the network
like this and show me what the
congestion that link looks like so this
is the reconstructed queue size this is
the reconstructed link utilization so
whenever the link is hundred percent
realization it overshoots into this
queue right
nothing is resident in my laptop so it's
all in the cloud so this is a great boon
for having you know Wi-Fi connectivity
and so on but if i zoom in this is
exactly the same figures as about but
broken down by whose packets are on the
link or whose pockets are in the queue
this is the attribution okay so now we
can say well my traffic is getting
screwed over by those guys okay shut
them down like this okay so that's the
idea of this dashboard a few more things
to say but I will this does actually let
me just tell you one thing about the
alerts and we're done so I picked let's
say over this circle that's a flow that
was transmitting a file from here to
here on that path and it timed out okay
so just this algorithm that we have is
determined that this is the culprit link
that is that's the link which caused its
packets to be dropped
okay because we can actually reconstruct
right so as someone who wants to go
figure out what what happened you can
look at that link and
this is the reconstructed queue size in
total queue size in great our flow was
just a small amount of bytes it got
stopped here the pink one and then
nothing happened and think was not
transmitting 400 milliseconds and it
started again okay so he's an innocent
sort of guy who got sideswiped by this
all this huge amount of background
traffic this is one other thing you can
figure out whether you caused the
congestion or if somebody else hurt you
right anyway well thanks a lot for your
patience and thank you I guess maybe the
interest of the brave we can take
questions of
[Music]